Звичайний полудень неподалік однієї з
залізничних станцій Берліна.
Безхатченки чекають на безкоштовну їжу, душ та нову стрижку.
Раз на тиждень перукарка Франціска Дінтер
піклується тут про зачіски.
Але не тільки про зачіски.
Все гаразд? Так?
Насправді
багато кому потрібна людина, яка потримає за руку,
вислухає, порадить.
Дехто називає мене мамою,
кажуть, якби ти була моєю мамою,
я вів би інше життя.
Зовні - запахи сечі, поту і алкоголю.
А в перукарському куточку Франціски пахне
шампунем і кремами.
Деякі з її клієнтів давно не були в душі.
Мені ніхто не огидний.
Я використовую дезинфекцію,
але в мене немає жодної огиди.
Раніше Ансельм працював журналістом.
Потім захворів, втратив роботу, а три роки тому -
і квартиру.
Ти завжди
маєш добре слово для всіх.
Можна тебе обійняти?
Дякую! – На все добре!
Вона мені добрий друг.
Я йду туди не через безкоштовну стрижку,
а щоб поговорити.
В житті Франціски теж сталася трагедія.
Колись вона мала будиночок, чоловіка і двох дітей.
Страшна автокатастрофа змінила все.
Цей удар долі став уроком.
Впасти – погано,
залишитися лежати – ще гірше, але взагалі не встати –
це найгірше, чи не так?
Якби не нещастя, каже Франціска,
їй би ніколи не спала на думку
ідея безкоштовно стригти безхатченків.
Я вдячна, що мої руки здорові,
це моє завдання, і як Бог подарує мені
ще кілька років, я робитиму це й надалі.
Франціска Дінтер порахувала,
що підстригла вже понад 11 тисяч нужденних.
І не планує на цьому зупинятися.